i'd like to talk more about your idea of
liberation of the heart differentiating
it from sexual liberation
well feeling is my inferior function so
i have a certain trouble
to articulate that but
the feeling function is something which
is
completely neglected nowadays
now generally we identify
feeling with affect and emotion but that
is only
inferior feelings for instance in the
happenings of young people
musical happenings they liberate their
feelings
but they it mostly comes out in strong
emotions
and it comes out as a feeling of loving
everybody or destroying everything
in a kind of all over the place way
not individually pointed while
differentiated feeling is to love
that unique person for its uniqueness
which presupposes that you are capable
of seeing the uniqueness of the other
of getting rid of all schematic
psychological judgments
of being able to
it is ultimately something irrational
and has to do with one's own development
the more
one becomes a unique individual oneself
the more one individuates in in the
jungian sense of the world
the more one becomes only able to also
see the other person as a unique person
and not have some cliche judgment about
them
if you listen to how people gossip about
each other you you can notice that
80 percent of what they say about the
other person is a cliche slogan
and does not hit the uniqueness of that
person it doesn't define the uniqueness
so liberation of the heart would mean to
be
to become slowly capable of
feeling and sensing the uniqueness of
the other's personality
and to love that uniqueness and that
doesn't mean
this christian all pardoning sweetie pie
strawberry sauce love of just
all loving and pardoning everything it
means on the contrary a very great
precision of feeling namely to
i notice that people with differentiated
feeling if one
talks to them in a not quite genuine
tone
or makes even a not quite genuine
gesture of the hand they are already
shocked they they feel the uniqueness
and they want you to be yourself
i think that's the most important thing
for a psychologist for instance to love
the genuine person of the patient and
to be quite openly disliking
all what is not genuine in the patient
then then it brings out the other it
brings out in the other what
he or she really is is really meant to
be
by nature and that is real love to love
a love which heals or makes the other
person whole
which makes the other person more him or
herself
and that has nothing to do with
sentimentality
or being just sweet or polite
exactly the opposite exactly the
opposite it's a very
uh it's very tiring it's it's having
constantly a
quick precise reaction to how the other
really is or is not or should be
you have sometimes in the anecdotes of
zen masters you
you find such things that a novice comes
with an ungenuine answer
with a tricky tricky intellectual
question and
and the zen master just hits him in in
the core of his real being